Moonlight cat podcast yo go check out
the interview I just did with this guy
zo Osama it's out right now but it's
time we get to the bars mate
let's go hit that [__]
[Music]
[__]
you ain't seen nothing
hey Savage Life shout out to my [__]
Webbie Lil Boosie
are we gonna bring this [__] to
the West Coast real quick yes sir
look
I
[Music]
but you already know that never [__]
with [__] always asking where the hoes
at it's time for you to leave let me
show you where the dough at check that
[__] Pockets bro I think he trying to
hold out on face shots little [__] put
that gun down I ain't really trippin
Lord [__] I got a full house speaking
on my name keep my dick up in your whole
mouth four and switching Lane driving
crazy [__] you know it's me I only got
one question why the [__] these [__]
holding me stop acting tough boy you
[__] Ain't Even voters me [__] must
be drunk as hell trying to charge me 33
I just made a 50 piece got your play
this time to eat knock your mans down
yellow tape go to sleep he say he never
lose I think it's time for him to meet
defeat imma keep sagging on this beating
through this big disease [__] we in the
club 50 deep it ain't only me I just
drunk a fifth to the face I could barely
speak taking all them drugs to your face
you can't even eat [__] think they
hard in the [__] and ain't only me hey
smash I don't gang I'm about to cash out
don't ask me for no money I ain't got it
[__] you asked out I was on that
mission trying to get it I'm the man now
can't ask for your two Secrets keep it
in and put your hands down [__] K
rounds this [__] wanna play now better
find a hobby cause your seats is not a
playground [__] say now I think you
think you're safe now cause all the real
[__] locked down in the cage now
better hit them girls when you hit them
shots rained out cause [__] killing
[__] cause they scared to take a fade
now bring the clothes back told my
[__] find a way out I made a way from
the East side we gon hang out hood rat
face taxing all black [__] I'm from the
East wipe your feet up on that doormat
sucking on my dick and [__] rubbing on
my six-pack trying to sub man you should
be whoa
[Music]
nothing
there it is you did Boosie proud man did
way be proud on that hey my God my guy
hey I know you just watched the new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week